it's a pretty simple lesson
different balls different sports
but the education secretary gavin
williamson told the london evening
standard that he'd met rashford over
zoom when in fact it was the england
rugby player itoje posted due to recent
speculation i thought it was necessary
to confirm that i am not marcus rashford
and whilst we're here my name is not
mario either just a simple marrower
tojay will do
gavin williamson tried to explain he
said towards the end of a wide-ranging
interview in which i talked about both
the laptops and school meals campaigns i
conflated the issues and made a genuine
mistake we corrected this with the
journalist before publication of the
story i have huge respect for both
marcus rashford and maro atoje who run
effective and inspiring campaigns but to
many it's not good enough
it hops back to
when
i was growing up and just getting into
football
and quite often you that you'd hear
on things on the news you know that
the comment would be yeah
apparently we all look the same
and you know it just keeps going back to
that when that's mentioned and i ever
saw this you think yourself how can this
still happen
despite years of campaigning to tackle
hunger among children in the uk marcus
rashford has never been granted a direct
conversation with the education
secretary he's also born and bred in
south manchester unlike a towjay who's a
londoner rashford wrote accent could
have been a giveaway
it's one thing for a minister to be out
of touch with football and popular
culture it's quite another for a
minister not to know somebody who's led
one of the highest profile campaigns
affecting young people this country's
ever seen
gavin williamson has already lost the
respect of many teachers during his time
as education secretary he's now added
two of the country's sporting heroes to
that list
tom parmenter sky news